[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUKE STONE: Hello, and welcome.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Luke.
We're here to talk
about 24/7 resiliency
and how we do it in the cloud.
So you probably know that
Google does 24/7 stuff with SRE,
Site Reliability Engineers.
And today we have a three
Site Reliability engineers
from our customer and our
cloud and our infrastructure.
So William is here
from Home Depot.
And he represents our
customers' SRE teams.
He's actually built an
SRE team at Home Depot,
which is kind of amazing.
I am Luke Stone.
I'm from Google Customer
Reliability Engineering.
And I'm representing
Google Cloud Platform.
Here's us.
OK.
And Mahesh is from Google
Networking Infrastructure.
And so he represents
the networking
that underlies all of
cloud, and then also
a lot of other Google
services that rely
on the same infrastructure.
So what we want
to tell you today
is basically how
we work together
to make things actually
reliable across all
these different
levels of the stack.
So public cloud is a little
different from your traditional
on prem environments
you might be
familiar with because
everything's changing
all the time and you have lots
of different operators going
on.
You can't just constrain stuff
into a command and control
kind of situation.
So it's more about
people working together.
And the example we'd like to
use is Home Depot's Black Friday
retail event.
So I want to ask
William to tell us
a little bit about Home
Depot and your website
and what you did.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Great.
A little loud here.
Thanks, Luke.
So as Luke said, I'm Senior
Director of Site Reliability
Engineering at Home Depot.
So I'm responsible
for the strategic side
of reliability at Home
Depot, and specifically
responsible for our e-commerce
and order management parts
of the website.
Home Depot probably doesn't
need a lot of explanation.
I think everybody
in the room probably
knows who Home Depot is.
We've got a pretty
recognizable brand.
Hopefully, most of
you are customers.
What you probably don't
know about Home Depot is,
though, we're a big tech shop.
We have a lot of technology.
Point of sale
systems, supply chain,
assisted selling systems,
merchandising systems,
not to mention
e-commerce and so forth.
Just walk around
one of our stores
and you'll see technology
deployed throughout.
We have a lot of
technology, especially
in the retail business.
Arguably, we have the most
complex technology environment
in retail.
Certainly one of
the most complex.
And our e-commerce part of
the business, as I said,
that's an area where
I'm specifically
working in the company, has
been a big area of investment
for the company.
We have invested tremendously
over the last five to seven
years in e-commerce, building
out distribution centers,
building out our
website capabilities,
building out a multi-channel
retail strategy
with our stores.
Really driving customers
from online into our stores.
So that is kind of where we're
coming from as a company.
We have recently pivoted to
a custom software development
culture at Home Depot,
so we're really--
not in every case.
We always make a build
versus buy decision.
But we've pivoted a lot to
custom software development
and a freedom and responsibility
development culture.
That's kind of the
direction we've been headed.
And putting a lot of investment
in our e-commerce platform.
And it wouldn't be a
good introduction slide
without a little plug
to say we're hiring.
I think that's kind of
required for a customer
to speak in one of
these engagements.
We are hiring.
We're hiring cloud engineers.
We're hiring cloud SREs.
And so just wanted
to call that out.
LUKE STONE: So what are
you doing with your website
project?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well,
I'm glad you asked.
So our website--
so we have gotten
to this point on a very
reliable, trustworthy,
monolithic platform.
Our legacy platform
is a monolith.
Probably most
people in this room
have worked on that, if
you're not currently.
Maybe thinking about
moving into cloud native.
Sometime in your
past, you've probably
worked on a monolithic platform.
So think about-- despite the
number of different development
teams and applications you have,
think about packaging those up
together, deploying
them together,
maybe into a shared middleware.
Could be WebSphere,
WebLogic, you name it.
Kind of the shared middleware.
And you have this
big iron database
in the backend that
only scales vertically.
That's kind of what's
brought us to--
it's really served us
very well over the years.
We've done a lot of great
things with that platform.
But it's constraining us.
It's constraining our business.
It constrains not just
our infrastructure.
I mean, there's data
scale and so forth,
but it constrains our business.
We have development teams that
collide when they're trying
to make changes and so forth.
So it was very important for
us to build that independence.
So like many people
in the industry,
we embraced a
microservices architecture.
Been working on this
for a couple of years.
Been chipping away at
building out separate services
from an e-commerce, so you
might think about a cart.
You might think about the search
part of the platform, content,
those sorts of things.
So we've been kind of
chipping away at that
over the last several years.
Actually, Ravi Yeddula
from the Home Depot
is going to be talking
about that journey tomorrow
afternoon in a
session where he's
going to talk about Home
Depot's journey to the cloud.
What we're going to talk
about today with Luke
is the kind of operational side.
So that microservices
architecture brings challenges.
One of the big first challenges
that anybody would have,
and that we had,
was you have a lot
of these little
microservices where you've
got to be able to provision
infrastructure again
and again and again.
That was something that
was very challenging
for us to do with our on
premise infrastructure.
The second challenge
is the fault tolerant.
So in that monolithic
platform I mentioned,
no way to run something
like that hot/hot.
No way we're going to run that
out of multiple data centers.
It's just the backend
database didn't support it.
You can imagine the
kind of database
we have historically used.
I mean, even hot/warm,
thinking about hot/warm
is still a very
expensive proposition.
It's not something
we can easily do.
And oh by the way,
also, you think
about Black Friday, which
we'll get into a little bit
here shortly.
We have to provision that
infrastructure well in advance
and then it just sits
around all the time.
It's just kind of sitting there.
Even with
virtualization, we still
have to provision that
infrastructure well in advance.
LUKE STONE: So how did that
work this year, like when
you actually had to face doing
Black Friday on public cloud
for the first time?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well, the
provisioning of it was--
per your recommendations,
we actually
provisioned a little higher
in them, in the regions
that we're running in,
just as kind of a hedge.
But we did it a few days
before Black Friday.
And then when we got
through Cyber Monday,
we provisioned back
down a little bit.
And we didn't, technically, even
necessarily have to do that.
But we just talked
about best practice.
If we lost a region,
then we would
have sufficient capacity in
another one without any blips.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
Got it.
That is one of our main
things that we focused
on when we worked
with Home Depot
as Customer
Reliability Engineers,
is we tried to say,
OK, how can you
get your microservices
to run hot/hot
across multiple
regions and zones?
And this is something
that we do at Google
all the time because we do run
globally available systems.
So we have some kind
of best practices
and good procedures for this.
And that's why we
have Mahesh here
to tell us a little
bit about how
that works for Google services.
He's an expert in our global
network and load balancing.
MAHESH KALLAHALLA: Thanks, Luke.
So one of the things
when we designed
GCP, one of the things
we wanted to ensure
is try to make
Google [INAUDIBLE].
What does this mean?
So for instance, we
wanted to put in--
the infrastructure
that we built first,
we wanted to make sure
that it was easy to manage.
So it had all the APIs
to make managing it easy.
We wanted to make sure that
it actually managed itself
a little bit as well.
And we also wanted
to ensure that it
incorporated a lot of
the best practices that
were built running Google,
basically the Google
website, and Ads, and Gmail
over the last 15 years.
That was actually bread and
butter when we were actually
thinking about designing GCP.
So what I do here is
talk about an example
of how we incorporated some of
this specifically in the load
balancing product, and how
load balancing actually
plays a part in actually
providing reliability
beyond just pure load balancing.
So a quick recap of how
load balancing works.
At this basic front,
the GCLB product is--
it takes incoming requests,
and then forwards the request
to what looks like a proxy to
a whole bunch of, essentially,
instance groups are [INAUDIBLE].
The interesting
feature about GCLB,
and actually, this will be
interesting in how we end up
managing infrastructure,
is it doesn't really
need DNS load balancing.
We don't need to put
a DNS load balancer
in front of the load balancer.
The load balancer itself takes
care of both geolocation,
as well as load balancing
across your multiple instances.
And you don't need to
worry about that at all.
And API-wise, the
way this looks is you
set up a global forwarding
rule, which is basically an IP.
And that forwards to
different forms of proxies,
whether it's a TCP proxy, or
HTTP proxy, or HTTPS proxy.
Which then, in turn,
forwards to different forms
of instance groups.
Now, here's where it
becomes interesting.
The way we recommend running
instance groups is basically
have instance groups that span--
that are actually
in different zones.
And this actually
comes from a history
of running infrastructure.
Fundamentally, when you want
to build a highly reliable
application, really running
it across multiple regions
is the best way of
getting reliability.
It's much better
than if you run it
across multiple zones in the
region, which is definitely
much more recommended
than just relying
on a single zone in the region.
Right?
As an example of this,
when Hurricane Matthew
hit the East Coast last--
when Hurricane Matthew hit
the East Coast last year,
it actually passed over
our US East data center.
And none of you actually--
if you were in that region,
you did not get an outage.
Yes, we had taken a
lot of precautions
about actually making
sure that the building is
resilient to a hurricane,
because it's a hurricane zone.
But ensured that there
was adequate fuel.
We ensured that low priority
traffic was actually routed off
the network so
that if we actually
had some network
failures, it would still
be able to carry traffic.
But even then, in
spite of all of that,
if ever you have something
which takes out a region,
you expect to lose about eight
hours or so, which would mean,
essentially, you would lose
your phone lines in like
a [? 10-year ?] period, right?
So spreading your instances
across multiple zones
is definitely something
that we recommend,
and something that really we
do across the board in Google.
And once you have a
load balancer set up,
you can actually use
that for failover.
The load balancer itself
is quite tolerant of--
it has some failure
mechanisms that are embedded.
As an example of this, when it's
pointing to different instance
groups in different zones, if
one of those instance groups
decides to be unhealthy,
for whatever reason,
then the load
balancer automatically
marks that unhealthy, stops
routing traffic to that,
and routes traffic
to everything else.
Now, we can use this--
again, while this is
automatic behavior,
this is a very useful
technique to even route traffic
away when you have a problem.
Like when you notice a
problem before the load
balancer notices a problem.
And we use this quite
frequently to drain traffic away
across multiple regions.
So as an example, say you
have an app that's replicated
across multiple zones.
And in general,
say you have set it
up such that you have
n plus 1, because you
are able to take any particular
instance group down, but still
be able to actually
use your capacity
and not lose availability.
One of the things you
can do if you actually
are doing a rollout
and you notice
a problem with a particular
zone, drain traffic away.
You can basically
use our API to set
the capacity of
that particular zone
to zero, which immediately
starts routing--
asks the load balancer to route
traffic to the other zones.
Now, existing connections
will remain in flight.
Of course, if your backends
are down, those will be reset.
But any new connections
and any new queries
will just go to the new zones.
Notice that this is
actually much better
than if you were trying
to do this with a DNS load
balancing in front.
Because if you were trying
to do this with DNS,
you would need to--
you'd be subject to DNS TTLs.
So say you had a
TTL of five minutes,
for about five
minutes, everybody
who was trying to--
till the TTL expires,
and your zone records
change, everybody
who's coming to your website's
getting, essentially,
has a chance of going to the
bad zone and getting issues.
This philosophy actually
also lines up very well
with a higher level
mantra that we
have in SRE, which is
around essentially having
an easy button whenever
you actually face problems.
If you ever need to debug an
issue in response to an outage,
you're wasting about 30 minutes.
Really.
I mean, most people, we've
either designed the system
to automatically
deal with problems,
or if it is clearly human
and the human is actually
debugging issues, you've
lost 30 minutes of downtime.
So typically, what
we do internally
whenever we face any
issue is the first thing
you do is head drain.
Right Normally you
have a zonal outage.
You immediately-- the
people actually just head
drain and continue.
And we use this very regularly
doing the rollouts as well,
as an example of one operation
wherein we use drains.
So one of the things
we noticed when
we were doing a deep analysis
of where we were getting outages
from is we were getting
most of our outages
as a result of rollouts
and config changes.
About 70% of them were
coming as a result of that.
And when we see
something like that,
the answer can't
be stop doing it,
because if you're
in IT, if you're
running an organization
which is thriving on change,
the last thing you want
to do for your business
is stop making changes.
So making changes is really an
important part of the thing.
But at the same time,
being able to do it
in a fashion which doesn't cause
outages is equally important.
And the ability to
actually move traffic away,
to drain traffic away
whenever you see a problem
is a key part of improving
your recovery time.
So as an example of
one of the things
we do when we actually do
a rollout is we typically
update or push conflicts
to a single zone.
We treat our zone as a
unit of failure internally.
And we do A/B tests there.
You can use a similar
philosophy even you
are doing a green/blue rollout.
Or if you're upgrading
parts, subparts of your zone,
we do an A/B test.
If you actually see--
anytime when you have, say,
your CPU load goes up,
or your latency goes up,
just drain out of that cell.
And then you can come back,
figure out what's wrong,
do a rollback, analyze,
move forward again.
This really helps
improve the MTTR.
As an example of this, once
what happened is there was--
this is before we
actually audited,
went through a lot of things
to eliminate global config
pushes--
there was once a config
push which happened,
which basically was starting
to get a large number
of our front ends down.
It paged a person,
luckily on the same floor.
And the person who made
that push immediately,
just because he heard
a noise, drained back.
And that actually-- in analysis,
if that person had not done it,
and we would have tried to
debug it after the fact,
we estimated that we would have
taken about 45 minutes to debug
this problem.
So in that example of having
the easy button whenever you're
doing changes is very powerful.
In both actually
allowing for velocity,
at the same time
improving reliability.
But a lot of this
doesn't actually--
I mean, there are
definitely corner cases.
I don't want to paint a
picture where you just
use load balancing and
everything magically just
works and always keeps working.
There are interesting
corner cases
that you need to worry
about whenever you're
running a large scale
distribution system that
spans multiple zones.
And let's talk of two
interesting cases.
The first one is, basically,
cascading failures.
This is something that brought
Gmail down for a little while
very early in Gmail's history.
The case is very simple.
Again, you just haven't capacity
planned your capacity plan
provision very well.
You've decided to
have your application
across multiple
zones, but you're just
pushed to a single zone,
and that zone goes down.
And immediately, a load
balancer realizes, aha,
that zone is down.
Let me route all the
traffic to the other zones.
But you have not capacity
planned properly,
and this is happening
during a time
when there's too much traffic.
And that, in turn,
brings another zone down.
Now you see a problem, right?
You end up bringing
your entire site down.
The interesting thing
about situations like this
is once you reach a
situation like this,
it's actually
difficult to recover
when you have users beating down
on your doors to get in, right?
This is actually-- casually,
occasionally try to say this.
This is trying to restart
an engine on an airplane
when it's actually crashing.
It's really hard when you're
being buffeted by all the wind.
And this is basically trying
to do a cold start when
you have hordes at your door.
And one of the things
we realize when you--
to do, basically,
what happens is
you try to bring
one instance up.
That comes up.
Again, your load balancer
says, aha, some instance is up,
everybody go there.
Guess what.
That goes down instantaneously.
You bring another instance up,
that goes on instantaneously.
We've actually,
again, over time, we
have worked out features
and we've worked out ideas
to deal with
situations like this.
Examples of this include
load testing standard.
Like when you
capacity provision,
make sure you have n plus 1.
That's the easy one.
Other interesting
cases are things
like have degraded failure
modes, wherein, essentially--
and this we use
across of search pages
and across of static pages.
So when you get too
much load, don't
try to just get rid of the
more complex dynamic pages.
Just server your static page.
This is something
that CNN learned.
I believe, in one of
their postmortems,
they wrote about
this after the 9/11--
when 9/11 happened,
they actually
had a traffic surge which
brought their site down.
And they moved to actually
serving static pages.
Again, an example of a
graceful degradation.
Another thing that
you can do is, again,
using the load balancer, you
can try to black hole traffic
at a single place so that
you can restart your engine,
start sending a little
bit of traffic in there.
[INAUDIBLE] a
little bit more air.
Once that boots up
completely, putting up
the next instance, and so on.
Once you're able to handle
that, bring up the entire site.
So these are all techniques
that we have learned.
We have talked
about in the future,
we incorporate that in
our customer engagements.
And we've written about
this in our books as well.
So just to summarize
the key messages,
the load balancer is actually
a powerful reliability tool.
You should use it.
I mean, it's actually very
useful across a variety
of operations, in addition
to load balancing.
It's very powerful.
There are definitely
interesting corner cases.
They're definitely
worthwhile talking about,
because again, most people,
when they run websites,
it's very rare that you
have a very stable traffic
pattern that doesn't change day
in day out, across the year.
You need to really be aware
of what happens at peak.
What happens when an
instance goes down.
These are kind of things
I think we actually
use in our engagements with
our customers, right, Luke?
LUKE STONE: Yes, exactly.
So the trick is to take
these gems of wisdom
that SREs have
developed over the years
with running Google systems
and try to actually apply them
to our customer systems.
Teach people how to use
the technology that we
have to get the most out of it.
Because you don't just
kind of automatically
get resilience from plugging
yourself into this load
balancer product.
You actually have to
know how to operate it,
and you have to be able
to know how your system is
going to respond behind it.
So what we did with
Home Depot is we
got non-abstract with them.
Right?
So we have a concept
in SRE hiring
which is called
non-abstract system design.
And if anybody here has gone
through an SRE interview,
you know about this.
Basically we say,
hey, would you like
to design a system for me
that's like a distributed hash
table or something?
And 90% of candidates say, oh
yeah, we'll have a hash table
and it'll work, whatever.
And then you kind
of say, OK, well,
what if it has to
serve a million QPS?
And now people start thinking,
OK, well, what's each query?
What size is it going to be?
How many backends
am I going to have?
What bandwidth am
I going to have?
And you say, OK, what if it
has to serve a billion QPS?
And you watch how
people actually
apply these numbers to
their specific design
in order to detect failure
modes and then make
a modification to the
design to make it more
resilient to this failure mode.
So we do that all the
time in interviewing.
And the reason is
because we actually
have to do it all the
time in real life as well.
And this is what CRE
is doing by bringing
the wisdom and practices
of SRE into our customer's
environment.
We take these lessons
and we just apply them.
So it kind of goes in
three-step process.
First thing we have
to do is we have to go
and listen and learn
and figure out all
about their application.
Otherwise, you don't really know
what your non-abstract system
is that you're working with.
The next thing you
have to do is you
have to analyze each
component of the system using
numbers and figuring out
what are the tradeoffs
and where it's going to break.
And the final thing you
do is design mitigations
and execute them, so
that you can actually
make a resilient system.
So that's what we
did at Home Depot.
And I'll tell you a little
bit about how it went.
First things first is
we just went to Atlanta.
This is a picture of AJ, who
is one of our CRE engineers.
And we're in Home Depot's
Store Support Center.
Isn't that great?
That gives you a little sense of
the Home Depot company culture.
They call their corporate
headquarters the Store Support
Center.
And you can see-- we
look out the window
and you can see a
Home Depot store 121
right across the street.
So we went to the store.
We checked out how
things were going.
We walk the floor
with the engineers.
And we kind of see what's
their culture a little bit,
the culture of this SRE team
that William's building.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah.
And you guys spending
the time with us there,
I think we spent probably
the better part of--
I mean, you were there on
site a couple of times,
but spent the better
part of three months
kind of working
actively with you guys.
And your engagement-- one thing
I actually wanted to mention,
you were talking about this
non-abstract system design.
I've done a number
of engagements
over the years with
other companies
have come in and
done some consulting.
And generally, the type of
consulting advice you'll get
will be fairly generic
architectural kind
of recommendations
that could be useful.
Tend to be more
application oriented,
or could be this library
or that, and so forth.
This monitoring and that.
But what you guys did,
bringing that practices
that Mahesh is talking
about, is the real deal.
I mean, you guys are dealing
with much larger systems
than we're dealing
with at Home Depot.
But we're still big enough.
And you guys are bringing pretty
impressive deep understanding
of resiliency and failure
points and so forth that really
rubbed off on Home
Depot's SRE team.
We actually looked at
you guys as mentors,
kind of helped us understand
the things we should be doing.
For example, a
wheel of misfortune.
And I interact with
a lot of other people
in other similar
companies that aren't
really tech first companies,
like us, we're a retail first.
And doing something like a
regular wheel of misfortune
exercise, we do it weekly.
This is something we
learned from Google
where we set up a scenario.
It could be in our
stage environment,
and sometimes it's in our
production environment.
And we do the same sort of thing
where we set up a scenario,
put an SRE, or even a developer
in front of a command line
and see how they perform.
When we're done, we do
a blameless post-mortem
and we learn a lot from it.
But that takes structure.
That takes planning to do that.
It doesn't happen naturally.
So you don't see that very
often in most enterprise
environments, but it
really pays off for us.
So I think just you guys being
around was good mentorship.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
I remember one story of
a wheel of misfortune
we were doing where somebody
was sitting back and saying,
oh, that's so interesting.
The traffic's not
coming into zone A,
but it is coming into zone
B. And it's very interesting
that we're losing
50% of our traffic.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Don't
admire the problem.
LUKE STONE: That's
what some said.
Don't admire the problem.
Hit rollback.
And then I was like,
OK, they're getting it.
Now they're getting it.
So that was cool.
So we just went to Atlanta
for just a couple days
just to kind of get
the lay of the land.
And then we get into the
meat of our CRE engagement,
which is to do this thing we
call an application reliability
review.
And it's based off of Google's
internal production readiness
reviews, which is what
we put every Google
product through before it
launches to the public.
And we have some
specialist SREs who
are really good at looking
through your design
docs and all your
readiness procedures
and identifying the
gaps before you go live.
And we have some of those
veterans from that team
on our CRE team now.
So we ran this thing.
And what you do
is you go through
and you identify what
are some of the most
important components, like
monitoring is always on there.
Deployments is always on there.
Like Mahesh said,
most of your problems
come when you actually
change something.
And we did load balancing,
because Home Depot,
very impressively, had set up
multi-zonal and multi-regional
configuration with
their backends.
So this procedure was led by
our tech lead, Matt Brown, who
happens to be an expert
in load balancing
and worked on Google
SRE's traffic team
for a number of years.
And basically, met with
the technical experts
at Home Depot on all of
these systems for a couple
hours a day for several weeks.
And really pick apart how
does this work, what's
your procedure going to be?
And we were able to
identify some failure
modes that weren't covered.
So for example, if
you lose a region,
then you're going
to instantaneously
get all that region's traffic,
boom, onto your remaining
region, right?
But the autoscaler was set
to scale at 60% of CPU.
So if you take that traffic
and thump it over to this guy,
you're going to
saturate the CPU.
So we're like,
obviously, you need
to have the autoscaler
set at less than 50%.
That's just like one
really obvious example.
But we came up with a
list of about 20 things
and we color coded them.
These are risks we identified.
Color coded them red,
orange, and green
in terms of their severity.
And then we had a big meeting
where we got everybody together
across all the systems,
both Home Depot and Google.
And we kind of said,
OK, here's where we are.
Here's all the gaps
that we've identified
that are major
risks that we have
to face before Black Friday.
And we got about six weeks,
at this point, to do it?
WILLIAM BONNELL: And
actually, I remember
when Dave Resin and you
first met with us pitching
the idea of customer
reliability and engineering,
one of the things you
said to us was, hey,
we're going to deep dive
into your infrastructure
and find some problems.
And we're going to
classify them, as you said,
high, medium, or low.
But in order for us to share a
fate with you-- and by shared
fate, what Luke and Dave were
saying at the time is, hey,
we'll be in the
war room with you.
We'll be in your Black
Friday war room with you.
But you've got to pass
our reliability review.
So any high risk items we
find, you've got to remediate.
So we kind of went
into it knowing
that that was our agreement.
What I was impressed
with was not
only did we have
action items, you guys
actually had action items too.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
Like for example,
we wanted to set up
monitoring across the
system so that both SRE
teams, both our SRE team
and William's SRE team,
could see the same metrics
on the same pane of glass.
This cuts down on the
amount of confusion.
And talking back and forth
over support tickets,
it just totally
takes minutes away
from any kind of response rate.
And we took back some other
feedback to the product teams
on the load balancer.
Like for example,
they were intending
to failover to a different
zone by adding another instance
group to the load balancer.
But the load bouncer
takes a little while
to start health
checking and actually
setting up the instance script.
And so even if that's
your plan, then your plan
includes five
minutes of downtime,
or something like that.
So those are the kind of
things we took back and forth
and worked on.
WILLIAM BONNELL: And I'll
mention one other thing.
We talk a lot about how
hot/hot and multi-region,
that was actually something--
I was talking about
the monolith earlier
and I forgot to mention.
It's important.
One of the things, we took
this golden opportunity.
I mentioned we
chipped away and built
a microservice architecture.
We built everything hot/hot.
So any customer facing
transactions we have,
we actually build
it to run across
not just multi-zones
in a region,
but actually across
multi-regions.
So I think we did a lot better
on your reliability review
than we probably
would have otherwise.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
You kind of aced it.
So we design SRE within Google
to be a very scarce resource.
And that makes the product teams
value it and actually respect
the recommendations
that SREs are giving.
Does that makes sense?
So we kind of said
if you want us
to go in the war room
with you for Black Friday,
then you need to implement these
recommendations as a condition.
And you guys executed on it.
And we worked around
your production freeze.
And you got all the stuff
done to the point where
we said, OK, yes, let's do it.
So lets talk about how we
prepared for the actual event.
WILLIAM BONNELL: And something
like Black Friday, anybody
that works in retail
can appreciate
how important an event like
Black Friday is, or could be.
Maybe you're a marketing
company, an advertising
company.
You might have the Super Bowl.
You could be in education and so
forth and have your peak days.
So for us in retail it's
Black Friday, Cyber Monday,
even Thanksgiving.
We pulled a lot of
it into Thanksgiving.
Something we're good at.
It's tried and true.
We do it-- been
doing it for years.
I've personally been doing it
at Home Depot for 11 years.
We start about six
months in advance.
We do regular
production load testing,
production destructive testing.
We do a code freeze couple of
weeks leading up to the event
just so nothing goes wrong.
War room, 24/7.
It's a really pretty big deal.
But this year,
this past year, we
had our tried and true legacy
platform, but we've also
got very important
critical services
that are running in
Google at that point.
So it was a pretty
complex year, thinking
about running both our on prem
platform as well as in Google.
I was pretty nervous.
LUKE STONE: I was
kind of nervous too,
because we hadn't
done this either.
But I don't know, we had worked
together on this as a team.
And I felt responsible
for the application too.
And we had followed all
of our SRE best practices,
as well as we could.
So we didn't really
have any reason
to doubt that we were
going to perform well.
So we started checking
the boxes in terms
of getting in a war room has
AV connectivity and real time
communications, setting
up all the monitoring so
that everybody can see
all the monitoring,
and working through playbooks
and scenarios about,
what should we do if
this happens, right?
So kind of worked
through all the stuff.
And I felt confident
to put my pager
on the primary on-call for it.
And then we sat down
on Thursday night
to kind of watch the graphs,
and watch the orders roll in.
And it was pretty
exciting, because I really
could feel that it's important
to have trust in your cloud
provider.
I could tell that you guys
were giving up a lot of control
from going off of your monolith
where you could-- there's
someone to call and yell at
and fire if they screw it up,
right?
And it's a different
deal in public cloud.
So I was really working hard
to win your trust so that you
could go through with
this proof of concept
and this test on Black Friday.
So what happened?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Boredom.
We have a saying in our
Home Depot SRE team.
If at any moment during the five
day event, or the other events
we have like that, you would
ask yourself, why am I here,
do I really need to be here,
we've achieved success.
We've done what
we set out to do.
So it's boredom.
Actually, I put a little
blog post up here.
When we hire somebody
new into the team,
we always indoctrinate them
very early on about Black Friday
and how important it is.
And of course, we don't take
vacation on Black Friday
because that's a peak day.
Even on Thanksgiving, many of
us are working on Thanksgiving.
So really kind of have scary
horror stories about it.
And we hired a
SRE out of college
who had participated
in this event.
And I just put his blog post
here up on the screen here.
It just said, all the
horror stories you heard,
all the wheel of misfortune,
all the prep we did,
what was the result?
Really, just kind of sat
around in the war room
and watched the money come in.
So that was success for us.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, I was really
impressed with something
that Naveen said afterwards,
which was that not only did you
have record traffic,
record orders and revenue,
and record up time, but you
also had record amount of change
going into the system.
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah,
not only just all
the changes, all the
microservices and whatnot,
but as I mentioned, running both
on our on prem and in cloud,
it was a very complex
architecture this year.
I think the scariest
thing that happened
to us that whole event was false
Stackdriver alerts on Monday.
That was kind of scary
for a little while,
but that was the worst
thing that happened.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, all the
pagers started going off.
But then we had the monitoring
set up, so we were able to--
we got on Slack, and we
got on the monitoring,
and we took a look at
it, and said, look,
this doesn't look like
it's a real problem.
It's probably a false alert.
And then I was able to get in
touch with the Stackdriver SRE
team, and they said, yeah,
this is a condition that
would create a false
alert of the kind
that you're experiencing.
So I was able to pass that back.
Yeah, it's a known
issue and it's just
affecting the alerting.
It's not affecting
traffic or anything.
So that worked out pretty well.
There was another
issue too where
there was a third party
service that was outside
of both of our systems.
It was just a third party
API that you were calling to.
And then it was some
kind of e-commerce API.
And it predictively
got [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONNELL: Yeah, that
was in our recommendations.
That was actually a good
example of degraded service
that Mahesh talked about.
That's one of the
resilience concepts
in your application, where
we depended on a third party
service.
That third party's service
have a little bit of a blip.
No big deal.
We could just still
display the relevant pages.
Just didn't have all the
information on the page.
So it was no big deal.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
We had discussed ahead of
time what our SLOs were
and what services
were critical services
and what services were
kind of OK services.
I mean, I don't know what to
call them-- less critical.
The one in question was
a recommendation service.
Like if you like this
product, you might also
like these other products.
So that was not critical.
The main things
that are critical
are like search, be
able to find products,
be able to put things in
your cart and check out.
So once we realized that it
wasn't one of those services,
we knew ahead of
time that we weren't
going to panic if this thing
broke because we had already
talked about our SLOs and
agreed on what was critical.
We were able to just kind
of wait it out and decide
not to react very much to it.
It was pretty cool.
So I was wondering,
William, how you
felt that this experience
impacted your project to grow
an SRE team within Home Depot?
WILLIAM BONNELL: Well,
the impact I mentioned
earlier was kind of
a good mentorship,
a good role model
in terms of how
to think about running large
scale systems reliably.
So that's actually
really paid off there.
And we've had a
tremendous amount
of success running our platform
in the Google Cloud Platform.
And so what's next for us
is continuing the migration
of our platform into Google.
LUKE STONE: So what's
that going to look
like, and how far are you?
WILLIAM BONNELL: It's
going to be busy.
We're pretty far
along, but we've
got some important
things still left to do.
But I'd say we're
easily more than half--
we're 3/4 of the way through.
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
I like your strategy.
I think it's an effective
strategy of carving off
microservices kind of one at
a time as you can stand up
a development team to run them.
And then you basically have
your monolith calling out
to the microservices
in cloud when it's
appropriate, and vice versa.
So you basically can glue these
things together with APIs,
and then we can monitor
at that API layer.
And it's really clear
what's going on.
It's a pretty robust strategy
to do it incrementally.
WILLIAM BONNELL:
And as I mentioned,
just a plug for another Home
Depot session tomorrow, Ravi
Yeddula is going to talk through
that, kind of the architecture.
So anybody interested in how
we did that and that journey,
please attend that.
The other plug is with you guys.
And I didn't mention it, but
at 5 o'clock, we're doing
the happy hour with you guys
at the [? Fifth ?] [? Nine. ?]
And one of the things
you'll hear from us
is standardized monitoring.
And so since we have all these
different development teams,
and they're all doing
different things
and we're kind of driving
that independence,
we wanted to make sure
that we standardize
in the way we monitor.
Otherwise, there's
no way we could
run all of these
services in totality
without some kind of standard.
So we'll talk a little bit
about that at the [? Fifth ?]
[? Nine. ?]
LUKE STONE: Yeah.
That's one of the
things that our SRE team
is going to be developing
over the next several months
or years, because remember,
SREs are software developers
who are charged with keeping
the systems reliable.
So we're going to
develop some software.
And one of the big gaps
that we see in cloud
is just this ability
to have a monitoring
system that both sides can see.
And it's like we can
see the Stackdriver
dashboard's that you
guys have created,
but we can't make
any sense of them.
And anybody who has run
a reasonably large system
on cloud and played
with a reasonably
easy to use monitoring
system knows
that pretty quickly you get 70
dashboards, and half of them
are--
they're kind of-- nobody cares.
And you have to really
be a day-to-day expert
to know which ones
are important.
So our concept there is to work
together with your SRE team.
Figure out which
metrics are going
to be our important metrics
that we're going to use for SLOs
and alerting.
And then we're going to
only alert on those metrics.
So we don't alert if CPU
goes too high, right?
We alert if checkouts
are not happening.
If people are
getting server errors
when they're trying to
put items in a cart.
That's a user facing error,
and that's the type of thing
we like to monitor in SRE.
You monitor the user pain.
You don't monitor
a cause like CPU,
because if it's not causing user
pain, then who cares, right?
So we agree on
just a few metrics,
like I think we chose
maybe four or five things.
It was kind of like load
balancer, traffic, errors,
latency, classic SRE book stuff.
And then we monitored
at the storage layer.
How slow are reads,
basically, from the storage.
And then using
that technique, we
kind of put the whole
application in somewhat
of a black box, where
you guys could reason
about it inside the box,
and we could reason about it
outside the box.
And there was a
nice, tight contract
that we had between
our two teams
about when we would
alert each other.
That was cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]